on the 10th of January 49 BC Julius
Caesar LED his army across the Rubicon
River in Italy an event he marked
according to the historian suetonius
with three simple words
the die is cast
by which he meant that historical events
would from then on proceed according to
Fortune and fate whatever happened
conflict was inevitable
the event could not be undone
Caesar had not only broken the law but
the entire political order
the phrase according to the Greek
historian Plutarch did not originate
with Caesar and it didn't even originate
in Rome it went back centuries earlier
to a line from the Greek playwright
menander the idea no doubt went back
centuries earlier than menander
sometimes human Affairs are relatively
settled orderly predictable
at other times people upend everything
at which point nothing is predictable
at those times political prognostication
ceases to be useful everything seems up
to chance
last night Democrats in Fulton County
arrested the former president of the
United States and the current leader of
the opposition
they took his mug shot like a common
criminal in defiance of centuries of
tradition and a universally agreed upon
meaning of the law
anyone left right or Center who tells
you that he knows what happens now is
either woefully ignorant of History
which today is entirely plausible or is
lying which is entirely plausible too
what was predictable
is that something like this would happen
eventually
America is not immune to history America
is not immune to human nature
fundamental political shifts have
occurred since the dawn of civilization
no regime lasts forever
and the only certainty now
is that the die has been cast I'm
Michael Knowles as the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the show we've got
extremely astute commentary from a guy
who runs a group called
I'm actually I don't think I'm allowed
to say on this network or in modern
American society the title of the group
that he runs but let me see I could say
Ninjas for Trump he runs a group called
Ninjas for Trump and no this man is not
Japanese he's very much an
African-American we'll get to that in
just a moment first though the
prosecutions we talked to Jenna Ellis
yesterday there's another guy another
another friend of mine who was indicted
this is John Eastman John Eastman a
great legal scholar a former dean of
Chapman law school very serious fella
wonderful guy who was arrested and he
saw the same historical parallel
that I just saw
he says that the Rubicon has been
crossed it represents a crossing of the
Rubicon for our country implicating the
fundamental First Amendment right to
petition the government for redress of
grievances
as troubling it targets attorneys for
their zealous advocacy on behalf of
their clients something attorneys are
ethically bound to provide
and which was attempted here by formally
challenging the results of the election
through lawful and appropriate means an
opportunity never afforded them or their
clients in the Fulton County Superior
Court
sometimes people like to compare Trump
to other world historic figures they
might compare him to a Julius Caesar
type but in this analogy it's not Trump
who crossed the Rubicon it's the
Democrats who crossed the Rubicon
by which I mean and I think John means
we don't know what's going to happen
nobody is going to predict what's going
to happen Caesar when he said the dye is
cast or let the die be cast didn't know
what was going to happen maybe the
Senate was going to win maybe Caesar was
going to win what that statement means
is that conflict is now inevitable
how do you go back
we have for the first time ever in the
United States
arrested a former president that would
be bad enough
but we've arrested a former president
who happens to be the current leader of
the political opposition who's who's
beating Donald Trump or I'm sorry who's
beating Joe Biden in a number of polls
general election polls whose 40 points
ahead of his next rival in the GOP
Primary who's a very serious leader of
the opposition
how do you go back what happens now are
we just going to stop arresting former
presidents we're just going to stop
arresting opposition leaders
you can't undo that the regime has
fundamentally changed and this is the
inevitable consequence of the of the
first time you might say the Democrats
started to cross that Rubicon and that
was in 2020 when I don't know are we
allowed to say this on YouTube I I'll
put it this way
when the Democrats changed all of the
election rules in some cases illegally
and unconstitutionally to give
themselves an advantage by opening up
the system to fraud and then they
stopped counting the votes when it
looked like Trump was going to win and
they waited a week or two and then
magically the Democrats started to win
that's how I'm going to put it because I
want to stay on YouTube let's see how
John Eastman puts it do you still think
the election was stolen
still no question
and you won't answer on immunity from
prosecution do you think that the others
in this case have a standing on that
people like Meadows no comments
did they do a mug shot and everything
inside no comment
thank you sir
the thing I love about John Eastman he's
very respectful guy is very amiable guy
even as they're indicting him he's he's
pretty buoyant
and he says yeah the election was stolen
now let's say you don't think the
election was stolen plenty of people
don't think the election was stolen
he does
so then the question is regardless of
what actually happened in the election
what are they Prosecuting him for
he sincerely believes the election was
stolen Donald Trump I think sincerely
believes the election was stolen even if
Trump didn't sincerely believe it
frankly even if John didn't sincerely
believe it every defendant has the right
to legal counsel
so why are they going after Trump
they're going after Trump because he's a
legal threat and they're going after him
illegally and they've gone after him
illegally since 2016 since the moment he
announced his campaign
is it really such a stretch to suspect
it may be they violated the law a little
bit at their best opportunity to take
him out I don't think so speaking of
taking out your political enemies the
story from a couple days ago there's
been an update to it so I'm glad we're
getting to it now
Mr pregosian who's the head of the
Wagner group or if you're fancy the
Wagner group in Russia this is the
Russian mercenary group very serious
fighting force
has reportedly been killed
the Russian Federal Air transport agency
has announced an investigation to
determine the cause of this aircraft
crash in which pagosian and 10 10
passengers total were killed
and now of course uh yevgenyi pragosian
has been a Walking Dead Man for quite a
while since he led a coup on on Moscow
on Vladimir Putin Putin tends not to be
so nice to people when they try to take
him out
so we've been waiting for you know a
stray bullet to fly into purgosian's
window or a little polonium to make it
into his afternoon tea and now it looks
like the plane crashed the update to the
story is a second
airplane that pagosian owned was seen
Landing in Moscow oddly enough and so
some are suspecting that he may have
faked his death and he might still be
alive and you might say that's totally
crazy he's done it before he did it one
other time he faked his death with an
airplane crash so there's a shot that
he's done it again now uh I At first I
felt kind of bad for the other people
who were on that plane but then I
thought you know I don't know if you're
flying around on a private plane with
pregosian you're you're a little sus you
know you're probably up to some fairly
dubious activities what's the lesson for
us
there is a political lesson in the plane
crash and potential assassination of
pregosian there's a lesson for us here
in America
which we'll talk about in one second but
when you want to talk to your friends
you got to check out pure talk right now
go to puretalk.com is your cell phone in
desperate need of replacement you know
the signs short battery life so you
gotta have a charger on hand cracked
screen gives the glass splinters it's
time to put that old phone to rest and
upgrade to a new 5G Samsung Galaxy from
Pure Talk for free
get a free 5G Samsung Galaxy with two
day battery life edge to edge display
Ultra strong Gorilla Glass when you sign
up for Pure talks unlimited talk text
and 15 gigabyte data plan for just 35
bucks a month plus
comes with a mobile hotspot if you are
not using puretalk you are simply paying
too much get all the data you could ever
need for half the price of the big
carriers on America's Most Dependable 5G
Network go to puretalk.com Knowles for
your free super durable 5G Samsung
Galaxy when you switch to Pure Talk
visit puretalk.com Knowles and make the
switch to my cell phone company Pure
Talk the official Wireless partner of
the daily wire head on over right now
to puretalk.com
Knowles if pagosian's plane crash after
trying to take down Putin teaches us
anything it's a line popularized on the
TV show The Wire
it's a line that goes back many
centuries before that in various forms
if you come at the king
you best not miss
it's a lesson for everybody
because Trump's rivals in the GOP race
are learning that now
someone like Ron DeSantis who's an
excellent Governor may be the best
governor of my lifetime
really amiable guy very clear political
Vision just all around terrific I don't
have enough nice things to say about
Ron DeSantis and yet we are beginning to
see that it was probably ill-advised of
him to take on Donald Trump in 2024 as
probably ill-advised because Trump is
dominant I suspect his poll numbers are
going to go through the roof after the
release of the mug shot last night
and now desantis's political career is
very likely over it's not like he can
just back away now
he took on Trump head on and if you come
at the king you best not miss Trump is
learning that lesson too though
Trump unlike a lot of other squishy
Republicans of the uniparty variety in
recent decades Trump actually threatened
some of the most cherished values of our
liberal ruling establishment
those values would be immigration those
values would be free trade and
globalization and those values would be
war and Trump threatened all three of
those no matter which party won over the
last 30 40 years you'd get more of all
three you'd get more mass migration more
globalization and more through through
specifically through free trade and more
war no matter which party got elected so
things were simpatico then Trump comes
in and threatens that and they tried to
kill him for it I mean they immediately
the moment he said we're going to build
a wall we're going to stop the migration
we're going to renegotiate trade deals
especially on trade that was pretty new
for a major candidate in the Republican
Party
it was a return to to an older form of
conservatism but it was pretty new for
the last 30 40 years they said uh-uh
we're going to start spying on his
campaign we're going to cook up evidence
through the fake steel dossier
we're going to work with Hillary we're
going to work with the Democrats we're
going to try to take this guy out we're
going to do it through his entire
presidency we're going to rig the
election and then we're going to throw
them in jail if he tries to run again
that's what they've been doing and so
Trump is learning that lesson too you
come at the king
your best not
miss the stakes are very very high and
if we point back and say well look
they'd never actually arrest a
presidential candidate well no look
they'd never actually spy on a
presidential campaign well no they'd
never actually uh persecute people uh
for simply voicing their support and
their their political dissent well I
know they'd never arrest lawyers just
for representing their clients
they never they'd never they never is
gone guys we are in Uncharted Territory
so people are defending Trump a lot of
people are outraged by the obvious
Injustice and
one of those people leads a group that
I'm I'm not allowed to I don't think I'm
allowed to say it on the air probably
not even allowed to say it in private
company even though it's it's a word
that has a soft R not a hard R so it's a
word that you hear in the popular
culture so I'm just going to say Ninjas
for Trump is the group that he leads a
lot of supporters going down into Fulton
County expressing their support for
Trump as he was booked last night well
here is to my mind I'm not being ironic
or sarcastic in any way here is one of
the most articulate defenses of trump
and clear-eyed views of political
philosophy I have heard from a viral
character in years
I'm here to support president Trump
you want to know why I'm here to support
president Trump because he didn't get
black men like this for decades make up
charges and pull them so I know Trump is
innocent I support Trump against this
corrupt two-tier justice system that's
why I'm here to show my support as a
black man for Trump and I'm wearing my
shirt for Trump 2024 and I mean
what do you think about the indictments
oh it's a bunch of it's going
around the country you know Finance
Fanny Willis she's a uh she went to
school with my sister she fully she was
full of so she's a puppet for the
white liberal that is controlling
everything she's in front but the white
liver back there pulling those strings
telling her what to do
that's what I think about it making a
fool of herself do you think it's going
to help his
help of course it is it's gonna Elevate
him tomorrow yeah I think we should make
Trump king that's how I feel
it we should make him game wouldn't that
be like kind of like Communists no
there's no way no Communists now we're
just gonna make him King but we still
got our freedoms and rights and
everything he for that yeah Trump for
King 2024. this guy I'm not joking do
not think that I am in any way being
ironic this guy is smarter and more
insightful and has a clearer view of
political philosophy then 97 of the
chattering class probably more 98 or 99
his name's Derek Gibson he ran for
governor of New York I think he's
running for congress right now
this guy is smart
and he connects with people because he
is able to speak in a way that's
entertaining and so he can go viral
think about what he said there even just
at the end when he said I think we
should make Trump king and the woman
laughs and she is isn't that kind of
communistic and
all of a sudden the joke kind of stops
and he looks at her and he says wait
what respect
is being a king is communistic do you
not know anything about regime and
political philosophy who on Earth would
say that monarchy is communistic good
grief lady not everything that isn't
1982 style liberalism is communist good
grief
no what does he say he says no it's not
monarchies have existed for all of human
history communism has been around for
about 200 years uh no there are some
differences Communists tend to subvert
monarchies too by the way you know how
the Communists have overthrown a number
of monarchies or attempted to overthrow
a number of monarchies the Bolsheviks I
don't think I don't think that the
monarch of Russia I don't think Tsar
Nicholas said oh wonderful my fellow
communists come in and kill my family
what are you talking about
she says no it's not he says it's not
communistic we'll still have our
freedoms and our rights he'll just be
the king
and he he's joking obviously but he's
not joking about monarchy there have
been many monarchies throughout history
that are much more free and are much
better at protecting people's rights
then
supposed democracies
there have been many monarchies
throughout history that are much more
free that are much better at protecting
people's rights than our supposed
democracy right now
here's exhibit a they're arresting all
the dissidents and the lawyers simply
for representing the opposition leader
who they're arresting to
so Preposterous there's a very shallow
liberal view that the only kind of
regime that could ever possibly be good
or legitimate is
democracy in the year of Our Lord 2023
because a lot of these people say oh
even democracy 20 years ago it was evil
it was oppressive we didn't have all
sorts of rainbow Flags everywhere it was
awful
give me a break
going back to polybius we know they're
they're good monarchies the bad version
of monarchy is tyranny but that's just
where the the one-man ruling is ruling
for himself rather than the common good
there are good aristocracies they're bad
as bad versions called oligarchy
and there have been perfectly lovely
democracies but there's a bad version
called mob rule where are we right now
but then getting to the to the first
part of his political commentary Mr
Gibson's he says
when he's asked what do you think of the
charges here do you think there's any
Merit to the charge he goes ah they're a
bunch of BS
that is the only response I want to hear
when the legal case against Donald Trump
is brought up because it's not a genuine
legal case none of this is being done in
good faith none of this is sincere it's
obviously a bunch of BS the proof of
that is one they don't ever prosecute
Democrats who even in recent memory have
committed much more egregious versions
of the supposed crime that Donald Trump
that Donald Trump committed but
furthermore
they'd get him for eating a ham sandwich
think they they impeached him for being
pro-russia allegedly they impeached him
for being pro Ukraine allegedly they
impeached or they investigated him for
being pro-russia they they impeached him
for being pro-ukraine allegedly they
said that he's an insurrectionist they
said that he he
had an in-kind donation to his own
campaign by Sleeping with a porn star or
something they said that he raped a
woman in Bergdorf Goodman's 30 years ago
even though she fantasized about how
wonderful this would have been there's
no evidence that Trump has has ever
spent more than five seconds with this
lady
it's just such obvious BS and I just
don't want to hear it from the the
chattering class well
um actually you know if you look at the
case against Donald Trump uh actually in
paragraph four it says that he you know
he actually might we should probably
start imprisoning the political
opposition give me a freaking break man
check your clock and know what time it
is
give me I just don't want to hear it you
hear this from very serious people even
Bill Barr who I still have a
considerable degree of respect for at
least is a political thinker political
operator to say well this case is
serious in this case it's less serious
it's all a freaking Witch Hunt man Molly
Hemingway made this point you know
Stalin got his convictions okay Fidel
Castro got his convictions Chairman Mao
got his convictions
they got their convictions through show
Trials of political enemies which is
exactly what we've got right now I wish
we could replace our Elite chattering
political class with Derek Gibson leader
of ninjas for Trump is much more serious
and clear minded thinker
you know the old ways and more
traditional practices
they're often scoffed at or demonized by
the libs but not all of them
the libs like to go back to really old
practices like really old occult demonic
practices the mystical practices of
healing medicine and Clairvoyance and
opening doors in for demons and stuff
all in Vogue for the lips
is it all fake
is it just a fantasy
there's just something more to it well
my guest Jen Niza
Nitza if you were to pronounce in the
Italian way explains exactly what
happens
if you open that invisible door and
receive messages from Beyond the Veil
check out this teaser for the next
episode of Michael and Michael and the
former psychic when I was a real psychic
medium I really wanted to help people
when you discovered this ability I
wasn't scared until I started seeing
scary things and hearing scary things
and getting touched by demons
this episode comes out this Saturday you
do not want to miss it be sure to check
out the ad free unedited version
exclusively on Twitter at M Knoll show
and daily wear plus my favorite comment
yesterday is from elberg gallarga 8909
what a name who says Mike Pence looks
like he's playing a Republican president
in a movie written by a Democrat
that is really specific and really spot
on and it's kind of a compliment to
Pence actually
in a way because in in these Aaron
Sorkin type movies the Republican
president type usually not
evil it's they're not usually not you
know hitlerian figures or demonic
figures they're usually just like really
stuffy you know really stuffy and
straight-laced and they're not and
where's the Democrat it's always he's
free-spirited and open-minded man and
he's just fighting for the people on the
Republicans really stuffy but I don't
know in our culture which is so
extremely free-spirited these days
perhaps we could use a little stuffiness
that wouldn't be so bad
speaking of attacks on political
dissidents
America's evil Top Hat Canada is going
after our friend Jordan Peterson
why are they going after Peterson
well they're trying to censor him a
Canadian court is backing this
psychologist organization the College of
psychologists of Ontario which has
embraced radical
gonna have to bleep this one on YouTube
guys radical
Theory and because Jordan understands
that men are not women
they're they're trying to take his his
license away they're trying to go after
him the the Ontario superior court of
justice has ordered Jordan to pay 25
Grand to the College of psychologists
and upheld the order that he go through
a social media education program
there was a headline you got to see this
headline I just saw it pop up on I'm
just going to pull it up on my phone I
hate to have my phone out just generally
but this this headline really spoke to
me
this was yeah there's a headline about
Carlos Santana
Carlos Santana goes on most insane anti
rant during concert this is an article
by Aiden vizieri what was the insane
rant
this is the first paragraph of the
article
Carlos Santana delivered a speech laced
with anti-remarks during a recent
performance in Atlantic City New Jersey
telling the audience quote a woman is a
woman and a man is a man
insane
can you believe this guy what a total
nut what a wacko totally insane
that article is what they're going after
Jordan for
Jordan Peterson he's and he's totally
insane
he's stating a basic truth why are they
going after him they're going after
Jordan because he is effective they're
going after Jordan because unlike most
people who come from the academy most
people even who are clinical
psychologists Jordan is reaching
millions and millions and millions of
people
uh they can't have that because he's
reaching millions and millions and
millions of people and telling them
really basic things about how to improve
their lives
we we make fun of because he says make
your bed you know clean up your room and
we we laugh about this
the funny thing is that such basic
advice needs to be stated out loud
that's how confused our culture is and
the libs don't like that so they're
they're trying to make an example of him
trying to they're trying to not just go
after Jordan who doesn't really affect I
don't think Jordan is taking all that
many clients these days he's traveling
around the world giving speeches and
writing books and doing movies
this is this is a message for the other
psychologists who dare to contradict the
prevailing orthodoxies on sexual
ideology
Jordan Jordan doesn't need the money
but most other clinical psychologists do
so it's a warning message to them
why why are people turning to
psychologists so much these days why do
people tuning into Jordan so much people
are anxious
okay they're so anxious that now
according to the Wall Street Journal
nearly three patients in 100 who entered
a Health Care Facility
left with a newly diagnosed anxiety
disorder that rate is higher than cancer
or diabetes According to truveta which
is a healthcare and analytics company
40 percent of people who take the most
popular antidepressants for anxiety
disorders because this is what the
psychiatrists do
not the psychologists who do cognitive
behavioral stuff we're talking about the
drug dealers who just say oh you don't
like your mom here get high take this
drug and then you'll feel better 40 of
people who take those drugs
receive little benefit according to this
study
some need to stop the medications
because they have awful side effects
and by the way that 40 number
who receive little benefit that means
that there's 60 who get some benefit
that sixty percent number of those is
probably inflated because research
suggests that some of the benefits of
antidepressants are just Placebo so
people pop the pill and they think that
they're supposed to feel better and they
do so even to say that 60 of people get
some benefit from these drugs probably
overstating it why are people so
anxious
whole host of reasons the obviously the
most fundamental reason when we're
talking about any aspect of the human
condition is going to be a religious
problem because
religion forms the the basis of our
belief about everything everything flows
from there our views of anthropology our
views of epistemology our views of
morality our views of politics
everything comes from the fundamental
question
who's God is there a god is there
meaning what does it mean to be what is
even ontology what does it mean to be
comes comes from theology so that's the
first one but then there are just these
political issues which is things are
unsettled I don't think you need to go
Pie in the Sky really abstract to to get
to the heart of why we're anxious now
we're anxious because our our entire way
of life is unsettled we're anxious
because the ruling class can arrest the
opposition leader and his lawyers and
his friends just for supporting him
we're anxious because the meaning of
marriage has completely been exploded
we're anxious because we're our economy
is completely up in the air and we can't
reliably make any money and even if we
can reliably make money most people are
going to be saddled with a ton of debt
with no end in sight
were anxious because inflation is going
through the roof and we can't afford
eggs especially I can't afford eggs
because my wife wants to buy 50 eggs
where they have three college degrees we
we are saddled with mountains and
mountains of debt we've got increasing
turmoil around the world the potential
of World War III no wonder people are
anxious
this is
this is a problem of not being settled
and some things fly out of our control
we talk to the top of the show about
Crossing the Rubicon and at a certain
point you you feel as though your your
future is up to chance
but we can settle certain things we
didn't need to explode the meaning of
marriage
we don't need to apply our country with
all sorts of Vice that turns us all into
Maniacs like drugs and porn and all the
rest of it we don't we don't need to
open up our borders and let foreigners
come into the tune of three and a half
four and a half million a year
we don't need to let criminals off the
hook we don't need to do any of that
okay and this is why I I often extol the
virtues of a tiny little Nation over in
central eastern Europe that would be
Hungary what Hungary has done hungary's
going through a lot of turmoil 45 years
of communist
oppression
Hungary has made a very concerted effort
to settle things to settle things in a
way that is quite traditional that
people can rely on they just celebrated
the anniversary of Saint Stephen's Day
the beginning of their country founded
on the crown of Saint Stephen
over a thousand years ago
we
we are not going to fix the anxiety
pandemic the real pandemic
by continuing to innovate and reinvent
the wheel and invent 10 more sexual
identities and
rewrite the Constitution and rewrite all
of our laws we're going to
fix the anxiety epidemic here's the best
advice you don't need to spend a billion
dollars on your psychiatrist I'm going
to give you the advice right now we're
going to fix it by being normal just
Endeavor to be normal and do normal
things will help you quite a lot another
reason people are anxious by the way
I'll have to tease this this will be my
teas until Monday you know I'm such a
tease uh homes are shrinking
we talk about how the Liberals want to
make us all eat the bugs and live in the
pods and own nothing and be happy well
here's that second one in action
headline goodbye bathtub in living room
America's homes are shrinking they're
shrinking considerably
we've seen a lot of shrinkflation
recently you go to the grocery store and
instead of getting you know 12 ounces in
your
in your jar of sauce you're going to get
eight ounces and you're going to see
things start to shrink well homes are
shrinking too the whole civilization is
shrinking families children countries
it's all shrinking well we'll get to
that hopefully we don't shrink down to
nothing before the Monday show and we
talk about it but now folks
are you sick of woke corporations
dragging your values through the mud
wash your hands a bit with Jeremy's
brand new hand soap Jeremy's hand soap
is the perfect solution for everyday
grit and grime not to mention it smells
amazing as it is scented with green tea
and citrus Jeremy cares about you so he
didn't put any of that paraben crap in
his hand soap not only is it paraben
free it's also free of sulfates Dei and
ESG for that matter plus it's not tested
on animals and it's made right here in
the US of a what more could you want
from your hand soap than to get clean
hands while keeping a clean conscience
so do yourself a favor
wash your hands of hypocritical Libs
once and for all Jeremy's hand soap is
the ideal addition to your bathroom or
kitchen sink as you liberate your home
from the influence of woke companies go
to jeremy'sraisers.com order your green
tea and citrus hand soap today
finally finally we've arrived at my
favorite time of the week when I get to
hear from you in the mailbag this
mailbag is sponsored by Pure Talk go to
puretalk.com Knowles for your free super
durable 5G Samsung Galaxy when you
switch to pure talk today
take it away
hey Mike I was just laid off from my job
doing spreadsheets at a widget Factory
so I'm applying to other jobs to other
widget factories and it's been a while
since I've done a job application I've
been at this widget Factory for almost
seven years and I'm finding that the
standard relevant information that they
need to know is updated to not only
include your employment history and your
skills but also your sexual orientation
uh so my question is is it wrong to
check the box to say I'm queer or
asexual or something like that
I don't want to lie to an employer but I
know that my application is probably at
a disadvantage if they see that I'm a
straight white male versus maybe an
asexual white male curious any thoughts
if you need to pretend
to be
sexually deviant to get a job
and then you get that job
do you really think you're going to
thrive and flourish at that company
I don't know I don't I see the
Temptation now
it's like the temptation of a kid
wanting to check off these
a racial minority on a college
application because he knows why people
get discriminated against
this this one though is you can at least
say well you know my great great great
great great grandma had high cheekbones
and might have been a quarter Apache or
something and this one though you you
can't
you can't even write this off to The
Mists of time and genealogy because you
know whether you're a little
um light in the loafers or not you know
if you think you're the opposite sex or
not and so you would be lying so it's
always wrong to lie
the ends do not good ends do not justify
immoral means but just at a practical
level
if your company if this company that
you're applying to will only hire you if
you pretend to be Liberace or you know
if you do a drag show on casual Fridays
that's not a company that you're going
to want to work for I'm not saying you
don't need money people got to get a job
but
there are better ways to make money than
that next question
hey movie star Mike it's the Chuck
Meister I've got a question about your
favorite movie Me Myself and Irene which
I just watched for the first time a few
weeks ago recently on music Monday you
mentioned a scene from The Blues
Brothers which is actually my favorite
movie because it's an absurdist comedy
with Catholic undertones set near where
I grew up I was wondering though why is
Me Myself and Irene your favorite movie
other than it being an absurdist comedy
with Catholic undertones set near where
you grew up I want a Roger ebert-esque
response because this film was much
raunchier than I expected for such a
Trad person like yourself love the show
thanks thank you great question it is
very raunchy I I wouldn't recommend it I
mean I think I saw when I was about nine
years old or 10 years old but I wouldn't
necessarily recommend it for
young audiences but to your point you
say well it's this absurdist movie with
Catholic undertones you might even just
say with
traditional wholesome undertones oddly
enough for a movie that uses all sorts
of vulgar language and has all sorts of
vulgar images in it It's oddly wholesome
the point of the movie is pretty
wholesome it's very funny it's just
funny at every single step of the way
but it
it's a
in being so hilarious which is what I'm
looking for in these kinds of comedies
it actually gets across a message that
is pretty
conservative and normal and true if you
took out all of the individual vulgar
elements and you just replace them with
a wholesome alternative then the story
of the movie would be
would be very very conservative would be
very Trad but it's it's so funny it's
it's it's Jim Carrey's best work by far
just I just love it
next question Dirty Mike what's up baby
this is Tyler or Halo in your chat hey
I've got a quick question about an
ethical principle you talk about on the
show in which immoral means are never
justified by positive outcomes wondering
if you could elaborate on the principle
in general but I've got two specific
examples I could think of one involves
politics and how Mitch McConnell uh
slowed things down in Trump's first
supreme court nominee so that Trump
could get that nominee appointed after
the election and Obama wasn't able to do
it and yet in the most recent example
Mitch McConnell sped things up so that
Trump could get the last Supreme Court
nominee in before Biden was elected only
one of these seems to be the true way to
go so it seems immoral for him to
support both and yet this led to Roe v
Wade being overturned which was
obviously very good another example
involves the Second Amendment I heard of
a case last year where an individual
carried a firearm into a shopping mall
where Firearms were banned and yet he
was able to stop a mass shooting so is
it ever Justified to use immoral means
for a positive outcome yeah it's never
Justified to commit evil for a
preferred good outcome in the case of
Mitch McConnell I guess I would just ask
what is the immoral action that he
committed you're saying that for the
Scalia vacancy he he dragged the process
out to wait until Trump got elected so
that they could put a conservative judge
in
but then in another case uh he sped the
process up also so that Trump could put
a conservative judge in
but speeding up or slowing down the
process of of a Judicial nomination
has nothing to do with morality or
immorality
it if he refused to do it entirely or if
he I don't know if he lied or cheated or
just but he didn't do any of that he
just
he just used tactics that were neither
moral nor immoral they were they were
totally at his disposal and ultimately I
think they were probably the if they
were either moral or immoral I think
they were on the side of morality
because they
they were conducive to a good end
without committing any evil in the
process
um
now in the case of what was your second
example the uh
can we go back to the site I didn't hear
what was the second example
we play that again
oh the mall shooter so a guy a guy's not
supposed to bring a gun into a shopping
mall but he does and then another guy
brings a gun in and so he shoots the guy
uh that's a happy outcome but he did
still break the law by taking the gun
into the shopping mall he couldn't have
known I mean the odds that there would
be a shooting in a shopping mall or
infinitesimally small if everybody just
broke the law and brought their guns
into shopping malls they're
in this particular place which is
probably a very liberal place where
people don't have good gun discipline
bad things could happen and if everybody
just violated the law willy-nilly we'd
have Anarchy about so I don't think that
is Justified though we are reminded that
God can turn bad things to good and and
frequently does and that's what
providence is
I hope that clears it up to the to the
broader point you ask where does this
view come from the good Ends don't
justify bad means just different
different approaches to ethics you know
one that prevails today is called
consequentialist ethics which is that
the morality of an action is is
dependent entirely on the consequence
uh there are other visions of Ethics
deontological ethics you know like Kant
and you know the idea that the
it's the action itself that determines
the morality regardless of the
consequence and virtue ethics you know
going back to Good Old Uncle Aristotle
which is has come much more into fashion
again in recent years so uh
I hope that helps Michael long-term fan
of yours thanks for all you do
yesterday I went to the dentist of all
places and everything was going
swimmingly the x-rays meeting the doctor
everything seemed normal until I went to
go for my cleaning
to my surprise the dental hygienist was
[Music]
okay before we get to the membrane
segmentum we can actually get to a
written mailbag today this is from Jason
good afternoon
uh The Love Guru of the daily wire
I have a question about a relationship
I'm in
I recently found out that the girl I am
with and love had a sexual past with
some of my high school classmates who
are still distantly in my Social Circle
well I don't want to judge her for her
past I can't stop myself from being
angry that they took advantage of her in
that intimate way this has honestly
bothered me to the point of me thinking
about breaking it off Am I Wrong to be
feeling this way how can I get past it
thanks well you're writing this in a
really chivalrous way but your problem
is not that your Social Circle if in
high school you know your former
classmates took advantage of this poor
girl the problem you have is that she
willingly slept with them right unless
it was a real violation or something
that's really what's bothering you is
that that her will which like the will
of virtually every young person
certainly a great deal of them was a
little out of whack with reason I did
this and you gotta live with it
so that's bugging you and I would say if
you can get over it then just get over
it you know we've all sinned all sin and
fall short of the glory of God it it
matters you know
how she is now how her how her conduct
is now where her aim is now where she's
going you know the Saints did not all
start well but they all ended well so if
you can get over it then get over it if
you can't if that's just too much of a
hang up and I get it because it's not
even like you're saying in the abstract
I know this this woman slept with a lot
of guys but you know look I don't know
these guys I don't know what their faces
look like I don't care I'm never going
to meet these kids but in this case
you're saying well I know them you know
they were we were in math class together
and I can't get it out of my head if you
can't get it out of your head if you're
going to be resentful about this just
break up with her
it's going to be better for her it's
going to be better for you if you can't
get over it
if you can get over it
if if you say look reasonably
this girl did some things maybe I did
some things maybe I did some things I
shouldn't have done and uh okay we're
gonna just call it there and move on
into the future then I think that's fine
I don't think you know
there's any particularly compelling
reason for you to dump the poor girl but
unless you can't get over it in which
case you're just gonna build up that
resentment and hold a grudge for the
rest of your life that's not not good
for anybody the rest of the show my
friends continues now you do not want to
miss it become a member and use code
Knowles Canada wlas at check out for two
months free on all annual plans
foreign
[Music]